hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
hi und hier ist wieder Nathalie Strauß
und ich Mirko Kasimir
an den heutigen Fall bin ich durch einen
Bekannten der Journalist in Berlin ist
aufmerksam geworden er hat mir nämlich
erzählt dass er mit dem Verbrechen quasi
zu tun hatte ja also er war jetzt kein
Opfer oder so aber es gibt auf jeden
Fall ein persönliches Erlebnis
diesbezüglich dazu aber später ja der
Fall ist nämlich auch schon eine Weile
her und der Täter seit 2018 aus der Haft
entlassen also seit fünf Jahren wieder
auf einem Fuß wenn auch noch nicht
wirklich frei komisch oder stellen wir
uns vor dass irgendwo da draußen einen
knapp 60-jähriger vermutlich Jünger
aussehender Mann herumläuft der
vielleicht müde wirkt oder fröhlich oder
ernst kann sein er ist freundlich und
zurückhaltend wir wissen es nicht sicher
aber ahnen die wenigsten die heute auf
Hans-joachim B treffen würden dass sie
es mit einem verurteilten Serien ver
Politiker zu tun haben der um die
Jahrtausendwende Hamburg und Hannover ja
ganz Norddeutschland in atemhielt es ist
der
8.12.199 Hans-joachim B später auch das
balkonmonster genannt schlägt das erste
Mal zu sein Opfer ist eine 29-jährige
Künstlerin die Schauspielerin Caroline l
Tatort ist ein Mehrfamilienhaus in
Hamburg Winterhude
Mirko wie ging das vonstatten
es ist 4 Uhr morgens statt und Menschen
schlafen noch es ist Winter und
Weihnachten steht vor der Tür
niemand hier rechnet in der stillen
Jahreszeit mit etwas bösen das über sie
hereinbrechen könnte
durch ein Treppenhausfenster des
Gebäudes am maria-louisenstieg klettert
Hans-joachim B dunkel und mit einer
Sturmmaske bekleidet in fast schon
akrobatischer Manier auf den Balkon der
jungen Schauspielerin Caroline l im
zweiten Stock des Hauses
Hans-joachim B bricht geschickt die
Balkontür zum Wohnzimmer der Künstlerin
auf findet darauf das Schlafzimmer
knebelt und fesselt die wehrlose Frau
und
vergewaltigt sie
nach diesem ersten Angriff auf die
29-Jährige setzt er sich ins Wohnzimmer
holt sich ein Getränk aus dem
Kühlschrank und schaut seelenruhig etwas
fern
nach einer Weile gelangweilt durch wüter
die Sachen der Künstlerin findet deren
EC-Karte presst ihr die Geheimzahl ab
und fährt darauf zu Commerzbank um die
maximalen 400 Marke aus dem Automaten zu
ziehen
er hat nun den Wohnungsschlüssel und
kehrt daher lautlos zurück
er vergewaltigt sein Opfer nochmals und
verschwindet
die Frau lässt der gefesselt und schwer
traumatisiert allein zurück
was für ein abartiger Typ
Hans-joachim B ist damals Ende 30 und
arbeitet bei einem Kurier
speditionsdienst er wird als netter
Kollege beschrieben kann sich gut
ausdrücken und geht während seiner
Arbeit sehr organisiert und planvoll vor
genauso auch präsentaten was ich aber
nicht kapiere er hat sogar eine Freundin
die liegt damals in Düsseldorf und so
ist es wohl eher eine Fernbeziehung die
aber immerhin schon zwei Jahre andauert
die Frau sagt später über Ihren Lieben
Achim wir planten eine gemeinsame
Zukunft es will mir einfach nicht in den
Kopf das er so gewalttätig sein und auch
so schreckliche Weise Frauen gequält
haben soll wenn wir mal Streit hatten
sprachen wir ruhig drüber
Hans-joachim B ist also trotz Beziehung
relativ ungebunden er hat viel Zeit nach
seiner täglichen Arbeit und dank seines
kurierjobs ist der viel unterwegs er
nutzt vor allem die Abendstunden und die
Nacht um Frauen zu suchen die ihn
optisch ansprechen das sind ausnahmslos
attraktive Frauen schlank und mit
blonden Haaren
akribisch beobachtet ihr dann
Lebensumstände und Wohnverhältnisse
seiner potenziellen Opfer
bis er erneut zuschlägt und das wieder
äußerst gut vorbereitet in seinem
Rucksack befinden sich seine Maskierung
und die neutralen dunklen Sachen
weiterhin hat eine Teleskopstange und
eine Strickleiter dabei um einfacher auf
die Balkone zu gelangen
dazu kommt noch die kleine Bohrmaschine
und ein Handbohrer zum Öffnen der Türen
und Fenster als Waffe nutzte einen
Elektroschocker der die Frauen
kurzzeitig außer Gefecht setzt
Klebeband und Kabelbinder sind seine
Fesseln Stofffetzen die Knebel
ziemlich genau einen Monat später am 9
januar 2000 setzt Hans-joachim B seine
zweite Tat um dieses Mal in einer
Wohnung in Hamburg Rahlstedt über ein
stabilen Nadelbaum im Garten des Hauses
gelangte auf einem Balkon in den zweiten
Stock dann will er mit seinem Werkzeug
die Balkontür Aufhebeln was aber mehr
Lärm macht als angenommen die Frau die
er sich auserkoren hat ist damals 35
Jahre alt und hat einen sehr leichten
Schlaf sie wacht auf sie nimmt das Licht
an und sieht sofort was los ist sie ruft
die Polizei während Hans-joachim B dann
flüchtet
aber leider schrillen bei den Ermittlern
noch keine Alarmglocken die Polizei geht
schlicht von einem missglückten Einbruch
aus und beruhigt die Frau die
Erfahrungen der Polizei sagen dass es
nicht sonderlich wahrscheinlich ist dass
der Dieb zurückkehren wird wenn er nicht
erfolgreich war
aber nicht so Hans-joachim B
seine Planung ist akribisch genug um
einen zweiten Versuch gleich in der
darauffolgende Nacht zu starten
vielleicht weiß er auch über die
Denkweise der Polizei in Bezug auf Diebe
Bescheid denn er hat einen Polizisten im
noch ahnungslosen Bekanntenkreis
diesmal geht er leiser vor und kann die
35-Jährige schließlich überwältigen sie
zweimal vergewaltigen und wie bei seinem
ersten Opfer mittels der EC-Karte erneut
Geld abheben
doch als er in die Wohnung zurückkehren
will sieht er dass die Polizei vor Ort
ist
sein Opfer konnte sich aus den Fesseln
befreien und die Behörden alarmieren
Hans-joachim B ist vorsichtig und
verschwindet ohne auf sie zu erregen
zwei Taten nach dem gleichen Schema das
ruft die Polizei Profiler auf dem Plan
zeitweilig Arbeiten von jetzt an bis zu
400 Beamter an der Suche nach diesem
maskierten Vergewaltiger der nun sein
Zusatznamen bekommt balkonmonster
die Verbrechen wühlen die Menschen auf
aber weshalb genau bis zur Festnahme des
Mannes liefern seine Taten und ganz
Norddeutschland Stoff für Albträume wenn
jemand über den Balkon einsteigt während
man schläft wer ist dann noch sicher
nach seiner Festnahme werden 11
Anklagepunkte verhandelt dazu gehören
sechs vollendete und vier versuchte
Vergewaltigungen als der Richter ihn
dann fragen wird weshalb er das alles
getan hat wird der Täter kryptisch ich
weiß es nicht aber ich muss wohl die
Absicht gehabt haben diese Frau zu
vergewaltigen
aber vorerst geht es im Jahr 2000 im
Monatsrhythmus weiter mit den Einbrüchen
und den Vergewaltigungen im Juni 2000
startet zudem die Expo die
Weltausstellung in Hannover die Welt
trifft sich in Niedersachsen und
Hans-joachim B der Kurierfahrer hat viel
in der Messestadt zu tun und er nutzt
das neue räumliche Betätigungsfeld und
wird auch in Hannover aktiv
mein Bekannter aus Berlin ihr erinnert
euch der Journalist da war damals in
Hannover um über die Expo zu berichten
zusammen mit einem Freund wohnte damals
in einer WG und wird schließlich selber
Zeuge der intensiven Ermittlungen der
Polizei
die Polizei fahndet nun schon monatelang
mit Hochdruck und enormen
Personalaufwand nach dem Serien
Vergewaltiger in Hamburg und seit neuem
auch in Hannover
es gibt ein vagisprofil des Täters den
die Ermittlung in ergaben bisher schon
ausreichend gesicherte Spuren um auf das
Verhalten sein Alter und vor allem einen
DNA Fingerabdruck zu erstellen
zudem vermutet man dass das
balkonmonster auf der Expo arbeiten
müsse da sich sein Wirkungsbereich ja
nun hier in Hannover und Umgebung
befindet das stimmt gewissermaßen denn
als Kurierfahrer hatte im Raum Hannover
nun in Bezug auf die Expo viel zu tun
die Polizei geht erst einmal von
stationären Arbeitskräften aus und
fordert im September 2000 ca 100 Männer
im Alter von 20 bis Ende 30 auf sich
freiwillig einem Speicheltest zu
unterziehen
alle Männer waren in den vergangenen
sechs Monaten von Hamburg nach Hannover
gezogen auch die auf der Expo
eingesetzten Polizeibeamten passen mit
ihrer körperlichen fitness- und
eventuellen Erfahrung im Vorgehen von
Einbrechern in das Fahndungsraster und
Presseleute sind auch nicht
ausgeschlossen und so tauchen die
Beamten auch irgendwann in der
journalisten-wg des Berliners Stefan n
auf
dessen Mitbewohner just die Tage von
Hamburg in die Messestadt gezogen war
und auch sonst in ein mögliches
Täterprofil zu passen scheint der
Journalist Stefan n spürt nun deutlich
in seiner Arbeit dass es sich bei
Fahndungen und Verbrechen nicht immer um
Dinge handelt die weit weg sind sondern
täglich über unseren Alltag
hereinbrechen können
der Kollege meines Bekannten war
natürlich negativ aber für die beiden
jungen Journalisten war klar dass dieser
Täter da draußen wirklich mit allen
Mitteln aufgehalten werden soll
allerdings bleiben die DNA-Tests
erfolglos und so kann Hans-joachim B
noch weiter seiner sadistischen Lust
nachgehen und Leid über viele Frauen und
deren Familien bringen
doch seine Tage als balkonmonster sind
gezählt die Polizisten in und um
Hannover ohnehin wegen der Expo in
Alarmbereitschaft agieren und weitaus
sensibler auf Unstimmigkeiten im
Verhalten von Menschen oder auf
verdächtige Situationen zum Beispiel im
Straßenverkehr und so lassen sie
vorsorglich alle ic-automaten im
Großraum Hannover auf servieren ein
gewaltiger Aufwand und so ist es zwei
Streifen Polizisten zu verdanken die
ihren Dienst in Langenhagen in der Nähe
des Flughafens Hannover versehen das
Hans-joachim B gefasst wird
in der Nacht vom 29 auf den 30 oktober
2000 fällt den Streifen Polizisten
während der Observation einer Bank ein
als gestohlen gemeldeter VW Bus auf der
sich einem von ihnen überwachten
ic-automaten nähert die Strategie der
Polizei um das balkonmonster dingfest zu
machen möglichst viele ec-geldautomaten
im Großraum Hannover Überwachung weil
sich der Täter ja stets an den Konten
seiner Opfer bedient
die Beamten wissen natürlich auch dass
gestohlene Fahrzeuge oft bei Einbrüchen
verwendet werden und warten noch einen
Moment ab was ich so tut
23.40 ist aber klar dass muss das
balkonmonster sein denn ein Monat ist
seit seinem letzten Verbrechen vergangen
er ist im Rhythmus treu geblieben und
folgt seinem verbrechensschema so wie
immer
dann scheint Hans-joachim B aber zu
bemerken dass man ihm auf den Fersen ist
und man nur noch abwartet bis sich die
Falle schließen kann er setzt zur Flucht
nach vorne und Brecht mit dem
Transporter los nach einer kurzen
Verfolgungsjagd versucht sich Hans
Joachim B mit einem Sprung aus seinem
rollenden Fahrzeug abzusetzen landet
aber nur mit einem gebrochenen Bein in
einer Hecke
er wird festgenommen
dann machen die Polizisten einen
erschütternden Fund im VW-Bus ist noch
eine gefesselte und geknebelte junge
Frau die seit 20 Stunden in der Gewalt
des balkonmonsters ist
Hans-joachim B hatte sie aus ihrer
Wohnung in Hannover entführt und an
seinen damaligen Arbeitsplatz in
Hollenstedt bei Göttingen verschleppt in
der Lagerhalle der Kurierfirma kettet er
die gerade 20-Jährige an und zwang sie
zu allen Sexpraktiken die ihm gerade
einfielen
zwischendurch Aas und schlief er während
sein gefesseltes Opfer grausamste Ängste
ausstehen musste
Hans-joachim B ist nun in Handschellen
sein letztes Opfer befreit bei seiner
Verhaftung gesteht er Gott sei Dank dass
Sie mich gefasst haben das ist nicht
ungewöhnlich viele Täter sind froh wenn
sie überführt werden und so legt B auch
ein umfängliches Geständnis ab dabei
kommt einiges ans Licht dass diesen Fall
zu einem macht der mich eben immer noch
beschäftigt in der Vernehmung nach den
Gründen für die statistischen Praktiken
und sexuellen Erniedrigung gefragt
antwortet er das gehörte wohl zu der
Rache dazu ich Rache denn bitte was soll
ihn denn zugestoßen sein dass er
unschuldige Frauen in ihrer Wohnung
vergewaltigt und deren Leben
Hans-joachim B wächst in der Nähe von
Bremen auf als Jugendlicher kommt er in
eine Situation die ihn in Kontakt mit
der örtlichen Rockerszene bringt er
versucht vielleicht dazu zu gehören wird
aber stattdessen von den Männern gequält
und gedemütigt einer der Rocker soll den
jungen B zu dem sexuell missbraucht
haben
Hans-joachim B steckt das nach Außen
hinweg und scheint sein Leben im Griff
zu haben Beruf und Alltag laufen
problemlos
bis er anfängt zu spielen und viel Geld
verliert bald hat der Schulden und wird
von seinen Gläubigern gedemütigt und
gefoltert
er ist in seinem Innern voller Hass auf
Menschen und kann oder will das nicht
verarbeiten oder mit Hilfe von
Fachleuten kompensieren
alles staut sich in ihm an und wird nur
von seiner peniblen fast bürokratischen
Fassade verdeckt aber warum Rechte er
sich später an ihm völlig unbekannten
Frauen und nicht an Männern aus der
kriminellen Szene
[Musik]
im Zuge der Vernehmungen und
Untersuchungen durch Psychiater zeigt
sich das Hans-joachim Bees Leben eine
krankhafte sadistische Entwicklung
genommen hat und das ist Ursachen dafür
in der Vergangenheit geben muss
B berichtet dass es ihm nicht um
sexuelle Befriedigung ging sondern darum
macht über die Opfer zu spüren und diese
auszukosten egal welchen Schaden die
Seelen dieser nehmen
die sogenannte Rache die er damals nimmt
richtet sich so wie es sich heute
darstellt gegen seine Ex-Freundin
Indizien dafür gibt es tatsächlich
sieben der elf Opfer von Hans-Joachim B
ähneln sich äußerlich stark sie sind
schlank und haben zur Tatzeit langes
blondes Haar wie die 38-Jährige Susanne
D mit der B bis 1998 13 Jahre lang
zusammen war
die Beziehung geht in die Brüche als die
Frau eine Familie gründen will und B das
rigoros ablehnt
später bekommt Susanne dem mit ihrem
neuen Partner einen Sohn und B beginnt
mit seinem verbrecherischen Rachefeldzug
was auch immer seine Taten erklären soll
es mindert nicht die Schwere seiner
Verbrechen es gibt ja diesen
feministischen Leitsatz eine
Vergewaltigung ist Mord an der Seele der
Frau was B geben seine Opfer angetan hat
schildern dieser eindrucksvoll vor
Gericht alle Frauen sind im
psychologischer oder psychiatrischer
Behandlung leiden unter Panikattacken
wenn sie allein sind fast alle Opfer
mussten die Wohnung wechseln weil sie am
Tatort nicht mehr leben konnten einige
sogar die Stadt die Schauspielerin
Caroline l die B im Dezember 1999 in
ihrer Wohnung in Hamburg Winterhude
überfiel gab sogar ihren Beruf auf
die Richter sehen zwar eine verminderter
Schuldfähigkeit Fällen aber trotzdem
kein mildes Urteil ja genauso ist es
Hans-joachim B wird im Juni 2001 vom
Landgericht Hannover zu 13 Jahren Haft
verurteilt danach fünf Jahre Bewährung
und darauf noch fünf Jahre unter
Führungsaufsicht es wird bestätigt dass
er extrem gefährlich für die
Allgemeinheit sei B kommt in den
Maßregelvollzug einer psychiatrischen
Klinik nach Moringen im Laufe der Haft
wird diese immer mehr gelockert
so hat er verurteilte
Serienvergewaltiger ab 2017 eine eigene
Wohnung in der er zunächst tageweise
wohnen darf
zudem stellt ein neues Gutachten fest
dass von dem ehemaligen balkonmonster
keine Gefahr mehr ausgeht
fakt ist dass die fünf Jahre unter
Führungsaufsicht auch nun bald enden
ich habe da ehrlich gesagt ein komisches
Gefühl der Mann ist frei und die Frauen
bleiben für immer geschädigt ganz egal
ob er sich nun tränenreich bei Ihnen vor
Gericht entschuldigt hat oder nicht aber
er hat am Ende seine Strafe erhalten und
unsere Gerichtsbarkeit sagt dass er dann
einen neuen Anfang wagen kann ich hoffe
nur ernsthaft das gelingt ihm auch
wirklich ja das hoffe ich auch und
wünsche mir dass es seinen Opfern
gelingen wird ihre Wunden irgendwie zu
heilen auch wenn das natürlich sehr
leicht gesagt ist es ist ihnen zu
wünschen dass das Geschehene irgendwann
nicht mehr so viel Raum einnimmt und sie
die Kraft haben darüber zu triumphieren
ja Mirko das hoffe ich auch Mirko ich
danke dir und ich danke auch euch fürs
Zuhören bis zum nächsten Mal bis dahin
euer Mirko und eure Natalie
den Fall des balkonmonsters haben sie
mit Artikeln der Bild-Zeitung der
hannoverschen Neuen Presse und des
Hamburger Abendblattes erzählt
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier Produktion Marvin schwarz